the korean language survival drama squid
game has been impressing netflix
subscribers ever since the debut in
september and many viewers have already
made it through the nine episodes that
make up the first season as fans recover
from the crushing conclusion to squid
games some have begun to examine the
show's earlier episodes for clues that
might have foreshadowed the shocking
twist at the end of season one squid
game tells a narrative in which people
rarely turn out to be what they seem at
the beginning even characters who are
introduced as admirable upstanding
members of their community
such as sung woo are hiding some
darkness for the most part the story
revolves around a simple sounding
competition consisting of six children's
games with 45.6 billion won on the line
for the
competitors who enter the tournament
however the brutal elimination of more
than half of those players during the
title game of the first episode red
light green light quickly establishes
the extreme stakes that these
participants face while the surviving
players take the chance to escape the
games after a majority of players vote
to suspend them many are drawn back into
the tournament by their desperate
circumstances there are several plot
twists at the ending of season 1 of
squid game but the true identity of oil
nam stands apart as the biggest one
while ilnam appeared to sacrifice
himself so gihon could win and take home
the prize money he is soon revealed to
have survived when gihan visited zornam
on his deathbed he reveals that he was
one of the founders of the squid game
competition and was participating for
one final thrill before his terminal
illness claimed his life however fans of
reddit who are now re-watching the show
have noted some pretty noticeable clues
laid out in season 1 of squid game
regarding ilnam's connection to the
competition one user points out that in
the first game red light green light
illness dashed forward with a smile on
his face and he was the only one who
appeared to have fun i wanted to just
feel something
just one last time before i die
while other clues hinted ill nam's true
identity later on his behavior in the
first episode during the initial game is
so different from any other player that
it serves as an early indicator of his
actual level of involvement with the
competition on her first watch viewers
might believe ilnam's story that he's
simply an old man with dementia but on a
second watch it becomes clear that his
glee during the game is because he
understands it all too well not because
he's confused ilnam's behavior during
red light's green light may have hinted
at his true nature but if you go back
and rewatch the first season you'll
encounter several other clues that hint
at the old man's true identity for
starters it seems more than coincidental
that he'll now meet
outside of the shop in episode 2.
ultimately iwo nam is the one to
convince kihun to return to the games
how many more of these chance encounters
did ilnam have with other contestants so
that there would still be a good number
of people to play the remaining games
that's not all episode 4 contains a
sequence where the contestants murder
each other when it's time for lights out
without proper food rations the
remaining players go after one another
to clear out some of the ranks when
gihan goes to check in on ilnam he's
nowhere to be found it's very possible
that he knew that the melee would be so
dangerous that he'd be better off on his
own rather than sticking to gehen and
his team not only that but illen is the
one who cries out to end the madness on
first watch this sounds like the
bleeding of a scared old man in
actuality it could have been his way of
letting the front man know that it was
time for the guards to enter to put a
stop to the bloodbath one read its user
rights when he stood up on the top of
the bed some was crying that he was
scared they stopped the game almost
immediately it planted a seed of doubt
in my head that never really went away
finally the biggest sin that illness
wasn't just a normal player comes in
episode 5 when undercover cop junhoe
finds decades of records of past games
he opens up the binder showing the
current players but the very first page
shows the information for player 2
skipping player 1 who is ilnam
considering that illness was a vip the
whole time it makes sense that he
wouldn't have the same biographical
information on file but the other
players get much like every other great
cinematic twist it almost seems obvious
when you go back to watch the show squid
game is available now on netflix check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]